Rebecca Gayle who spent all morning
outside a Border Patrol facility in
McAllen Texas she is covering the
separation of migrant children from
their parents Gail let me ask you this I
know you spoke with my name is Gomez
where are they coming from where they
fleen yeah they're coming from there are
primarily three countries Nora we're
told
Guatemala El Salvador and Honduras and
it's interesting when we walked into the
room they don't even know who we are
they don't know we're journalists they
don't know that we that we are there to
tell their story so they're looking at
us sort of blankly like who are these
people they don't realize that we have
come to talk to them so that was
interesting and I started thinking about
thinking about this just think what it
would take for any of us to say you know
what I'm leaving America to go to a
country where you're probably not going
to be welcome they don't speak your
language but you still think that that
is a better place for you to be and
that's what these people are facing this
just in from David Wagner who says the
Border Patrol people have reached out to
us they are very uncomfortable in their
words with his characterization of the
words cages they said it's not
inaccurate but they're very
uncomfortable with using the word cages
they said they may be cages but they're
not being treated like animals I know a
lot of people looking at that don't
entirely see the distinction Gail the
expectations of the people you talk to
what did they think would happen to them
when they got here well you know what's
interesting John there's a lot of people
that we talked to they have relatives
here they were going to North Carolina
they were going to California they were
going to New York they were going to
Chicago so their expectation is that
they would come they would fill out the
proper papers pay the amount of money
that they say they have to pay and that
they would be on their way they said
look we are just trying to do a better
life to escape the horrors that are
happening in our country you know Gail I
think that was your expectation people
are understanding it's traumatic to be
separated the journey over is traumatic
just getting to the United States of
America yes
it is a journey to get get here Alex and
it is complicated but the two separate a
mother from their child is just and it's
a primal it's a primal need that we all
have and anybody with a child can
understand that
all right Gail will see you tomorrow
thanks so much that does it for us we'll
see you tomorrow on CBS this morning
you